[Musique]
je le vois je le sens je le sais
je le sens je
son sourire nous ment pas qui vient me
chercher
quand tu viens me chercher
les choses qu'il est
chemin qui l'attend
[Musique]
je crois pourtant qu'il est seul mais
qu'il fera d'autres villes
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
je suis
quelques parents
aujourd'hui
notre attention
[Musique]
il est vrai
atta
[Musique]
les mets
il peut décider
quand c'est pas le
g
moi je lai les jeux
[Musique]
ne pas
témoin
[Applaudissements]
d
en se battant pour benhaim jadis tous
voulaient c'est pour toi visite du parc
car à chaque fois par cas nicolas
besnard
[Musique]
il
charmé du début je veux le début je peux
l'intro je veux pas trop ça dort un trou
j'adore l'intro ils sont en train de
chercher à hicha il très mal j ch ar non
pas là disent athées aïcha l'a10 à
savoir voilà messieurs
mais mais non
le début
a ici
[Musique]
attention
g
[Musique]
elle est passée à côté de droit
sans un regard elle ça va je n'ai rien
lâché divers éléments tout est pour toi
aussi
jours
[Musique]
si tous
les
billets
si tu
[Applaudissements]
vous
pouvez
et moi
merci qui
pour éclairer les yeux
les gros ménage
menaïl polgar deux mois
[Applaudissements]
pour cassady pour cassany je me lève sur
le bol d'air
il avait été du début vous la mettez du
début voilà mettez du début pour
castaldi je veux les yeux revolver
allemagne c'est pour toi cas cela a
laissé bol c'est bon et beau c'est beau
c'est bon bah oui c'est les petits
revolver mais
ça peut faire mouche comme on dit dans
le média karaoke attention c'est parti à
les chanter
[Musique]
mais
spécialisé liberté
les cheveux en arrière et j'aime ça
s est dessinée sur des jupes fendues des
feux de vie
et j'aime assez comme ça c'est bon sens
tellement si belle
santé
[Musique]
mensuel je lève mon si fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je mets le
elle a
qui tu es là tu y vas
bas touchés c'est fou
et
les yeux très bas
mais
[Applaudissements]
delphine wespiser
je vais demander une chanson de mariah
carey là bas depuis le début en bas oui
oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les deux tellement guerre
[Musique]
epyon de
voiture
m
[Musique]
tuc et oui
leucate chauffer le st
nous comme ça hu
pescara
ok tu vois
une
fois elle essaie de tuer
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu
m'as
sauvé
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mettez moi voilà geste aimable tout de
même ma mère havas est humaine idéal tu
devrais dérange
vraiment eu mal et non un peu fou comme
ça le sexe est un peu fou c'est un peu
fou
[Applaudissements]
graphique à serge lama
conquis l'afrique mais alors pas du tout
l'afrique
c'est pas du bal pour moi
c'est la présente vous trouvez pas pour
moi c'est vrai mettez moi ce que vous
voulez oui mars à la longue c'est bien
non non non non non non non mais tu es
moins que oui pour vous asseyons meuse a
ajouté l'américain
joe dassin
[Rires]
c'est parti mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez mais tu es ce que vous voulez
après j'ai une chanson pour toison plus
rien vous êtes toujours
[Rires]
m
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
salon
séguin au frigo
hello to be
c'est niet
d'ici là
[Musique]
m
j'aime
[Musique]
jeudi
[Applaudissements]
bravo
alors
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
faïd est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai je pars lundi le roumain
l'amérique c'est simple c'est un peureux
ou dans
des bus allez c'est parti mais taylor
[Musique]
je dois m'en bats les
je n'ai plus qu'à acheter
plus que je suis et qui ça la met
[Applaudissements]
j'attends des
chemins
tant de gens
je vais bien je l'accueille
sarah peu de chagrin la médina
et la mer
m
je peux là
et je
[Musique]
six états
le son
tout le site
que les sirènes
le bateau
chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très bon cru
il est reconnu sur toi de moi dans leur
bébé
mort de quelqu un qu est la trompe
d'éléphant
au raymond mettez moi une chanson triste
tu vois une chanson des principes
[Musique]
bon bien mettez le
manteau
m'adore
c'est la voie du début est hélas mois du
début de l'année qui charrie j'adore
c'est pas
les mecs ça va ya de la friture aulas a
tant besoin de faire des frites
attention c'est parti connaît par coeur
attention ces partis ont mené la voyez
là
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors son vieux pardessus rap et s'en
aller libérer
petit matin
[Musique]
les bienvenus car seuls les autres jours
c'était la grève la ville allait gagner
comme il peut
mon vieux
et des blindés voir la mer
ces lois c'était pas la misère
c'était pas non plus un radis
je sais tant pis a permis non
merci je crois que
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
way you lie part ii / ap il a pris
pendant des années le même autobus de
banlieue ouais bon vieux gréements jeu
même si c'était pour toi
géraldine a alors
je vous inspire pas gdam jours pour le
plaisir
[Applaudissements]
on a cherché vous inquiétez pas ça
m'arrivait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
voilà mais pour le messie
[Musique]
une fille dans la rue
est ce lui
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
mais encore là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sourit
le plaisir
[Musique]
non
l'enfant
c'est bon
[Musique]
bonjour
qui
n'a pas de prix
oui
m géraldine très bon choix des
chaussures plates et pourtant
[Applaudissements]
et enfin pour toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça grimpe
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la montre
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
liberté
chérie
data
c'est fragile
matthieu lamarre
[Musique]
bourgeot t on
c'était pour toi
ça fait du camp pour hacker dans
l'émission la même
histoire est plus vus ils voulaient du
fait je voulais qu passe lolita
nancy ouais tu voulais lolita c'est vrai
oui aussi
ce sera la dernière j'ai connu pour ses
soirées
c'est le début quitte à porter deuxième
chanson je vous allez voir je suis
extrêmement feeling quand je chante on
va faire une entrée
[Applaudissements]
sert à rien ou bien
haut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gelée lolita
collégiens d'autres
mais bhl
je m'appelle au lit table
tous ces gentils
on
par exemple ces fameux compteur
mais ça je vois les autres
je crée sur
et j'adore tout
m
[Musique]
il va
les chaînes pas
le guen
si l'aide soit jours à peine
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
après nommait
je m'appelle au lit j'adore j'adore ça
doit